friday edition of pft live slash pftpm
hiatus style heading to the beach
next week undisclosed location reminder
there will be a full security force here
at the undisclosed address in west
virginia so don't mess around as i once
told chris sims
no need for a gate at the bottom of the
hill when he got a shotgun
at the top on that happy note let's get
to some of the news and
thank you in advance to saints gm mickey
loomis for appearing on the adam shine
podcast
on thursday because it gave us things
about which to write
and about which to speak and i'm going
to start with the thing that
resonated for me from the mickey loomis
interview the question of whether and to
what extent
the new orleans saints pursued
considered
contemplated the possibility of signing
tom brady when he became a free agent
in 2020 i thought it was odd to say the
least that multiple sunday splash
reports on the first sunday
of the 2020 regular season when the
buccaneers were visiting the saints to
get things rolling tom brady and drew
brees the first of what would be
three battles that year that day we
heard for the first time
how close the saints were to signing
tom brady and those reports suggested
and there have been reports since then
suggesting
that the saints were toying with the
idea of signing brady
even after drew brees had informed
the team he'd be back for the 2020
season
mickey loomis was asked about the brady
consideration on thursday by adam shine
and what loomis said was
and i'm paraphrasing here because he
didn't get into detail and that's always
the smart thing to do but he said once
we knew drew was coming back that was
the end
of any other discussion so that means
officially and look i'm the first to say
don't believe anything anyone tells you
because there's a
strategic objective that's at play that
may not
mesh with being honest but the official
position from mickey loomis is once they
knew brees was coming back they weren't
pursuing
anyone else now the thought i had
yesterday and this is where cynicism
comes into play and you look at the
various connections among individuals in
the nfl don yee who represents
tom brady also represents sean payton
and to the extent that ye may have been
telling other teams the saints were at
the table even after brees told the
saints
that he's coming back maybe
that has kind of gotten around and maybe
ye was doing that with the blessing of
peyton his
other client because look if it comes
down to the bucks and
obviously it did if there is another
team out there
that's in your division that is
contemplating signing tom brady
that's a way to get more stuff out of
the buccaneers and that's one of the
things i heard last week when we were
trying to figure out
the mystery team that tom brady was
referring to when he appeared on
the shop on hbo the question of whether
brady wanted too much that the the
theory is the raiders were the team that
bowed out late
and that thus derek carr was the unnamed
mother effort of whom brady was
referring on the shop
that the raiders just thought this guy
wants too much and one of the things he
wanted as i understand it and i think he
got it in tampa
free license in the facility and around
the team for alex guerrero the tb12 guru
that
had gotten frozen out of new england
eventually
so hey if what
whatever else the buccaneers have to do
that they otherwise aren't inclined to
do to get tom brady
if thinking that brady's other
alternative is to go play for the saints
that would seem to be the thing that
would get the buccaneers to
give up more chew up more salary cap
space whatever it may be you don't want
it to be easy for one of your top rivals
you want it to be difficult and at the
end of the day it looked like it worked
because the saints swept the bucks in
the regular season but obviously
for any of us who have been paying
attention to football for the past
several months we know that the
buccaneers beat the saints
when it mattered most in the divisional
round of the playoffs
another topic that loomis got into and
we have the stories at pft with the full
quotes i'm not going to read anything
verbatim
in part because i don't have it in front
of me but mickey loomis talked about the
two main candidates to become
quarterback of the team this year
starter who will it be will it be taysom
hill
will it be jameis winston winston became
a free agent after the 2020 season he
signed a deal that pays him
less than what taysom hill is due to
make this year i don't know that that
really matters here's what i go back to
in 2020 when drew brees got injured
remember he had
i think more broken ribs than there are
ribs in the human body
but when brees got injured and we spent
a whole week
thinking based on reporting that was
being done at the time that jameis
winston would be the starter and then
all of a sudden
we find out friday of the week in
advance of i think it was a game against
the falcons
that taysom hill would get the nod
what sean payton eventually said at that
time in that general
period was that he had given his word to
taysom hill
that if brees got injured during the
2020 season
hill would get the opportunity to
replace him
he had made that promise to taysom hill
because the year before obviously it was
teddy bridgewater who went 5-0
while drew brees was injured he had that
thumb injury that he suffered against
the rams i believe it was
so last year
hill had been given that promise and
remember hill
signed a new contract in the offseason
was going to be a restricted free agent
had to decide to stay with the saints
re-up with the saints
and i think part of that conversation
was as
peyton told the world he'd given hill
his word
that he'd get the chance if brees got
injured
but at that same time peyton also said
he promised jameis winston he'll have a
chance to compete for the starting job
in 2021
now that was kind of odd at the time
because winston's only under contract
through 2020 but
it it made it clear that the saints
wanted to bring winston back
winston became a free agent no one
flocked to try to sign him
to the kind of contract that would make
him a clear-cut starter like the
panthers did with teddy bridgewater in
2020
so winston returns and i think that he's
been promised multiple times now he gets
a chance he gets a chance to compete
and we'll find out who the better option
is now
if you go with winston you still have
the taysom hill package
that's an attraction that actually hurts
hill the fact that he can do all those
other things about which loomis rave to
adam shine
hurts him in the competition to be the
starter because hey if it's about
putting your best 11 on the field
let winston play quarterback let taysom
hill be the jack of all trades
and do different things but however it
plays out
they're going to go with the guy that
they think gives them the best chance to
win
and it could be something that's decided
on a week by week basis
it could be something that's decided on
a drive-by drive or play-by-play
basis but it will be a fair competition
i believe
and i think sean payton will go with the
guy that he thinks deserves to play
and it may not be a 17-game decision
that's made
week one against the green bay packers
and the other factor sims and i have
talked about this on pft live
payton has that proclivity of coming up
with plays anywhere and everywhere
up to and including kickoff sunday
morning breakfast
got some new plays that i came up with
here they are
which guy is going to be better suited
to adapting to those plays
to incorporating those plays and
performing them the way that sean payton
wants them to be performed brees could
do it hill's been around to watch it but
winston was too remember how emotional
winston was when brees retired how much
winston learned last year about how to
be a pro
one of the things about being a pro is
being flexible and adaptable
you never know what's going to get
thrown at you you have to just keep
going
you just keep going no matter what the
potential distraction may be no matter
what
the challenge may be and one of the
biggest challenges of playing
quarterback for sean payton
being ready on sunday morning to find
out that the game plan has been expanded
by several more plays it'd be fun to
watch because look bottom line is
saints continue to be a contender in the
nfc
this is nothing against rubrice our new
nbc colleague
but it's no secret the armed strength
wasn't what it used to be
later in his career with hill and
winston the armed strength is there
and the farther down the field
that the quarterback can throw the ball
the more
of the field that the defense has to
defend
it's a testament to how good drew brees
is
at diagnosing and executing the plays
that are called
in obvious partnership with sean payton
that that offense can operate at a very
high level
even though the defense doesn't feel
compelled
to cover all the way to the goal line
now this year
you add in the reality that if you creep
up to the line of scrimmage
someone may run right by you and that
ball is going to go over the top and
it's not going to be
underthrown it's going to land right in
the hands of the wide open receiver i
got a
theory hypothesis i don't know what it
is about aaron rodgers i i look we're
we're
two weeks and a few days away from
finding out whether he shows up or
doesn't show up for training camp and
the reason we're talking about it is
he's had every opportunity to let us
know whether or not he's going to be
there
and he has chosen not to tell us we'll
see
so until we find out it's
it's free and fair and proper
to play out the various scenarios i
think he's going to show up
i think that mark murphy the ceo of the
packers wants him to not show up
i think murphy would prefer number one
rogers becomes the clear villain in all
of this by not showing up hey you're
under contract got here under your
contract
under your contract you're under
contract for three more years contract
contract contract
you're in the wrong for not showing up
you signed this contract
you committed to this team you need to
be here that's
what the attitude likely will be if
history is a guide
the team's fans always line up behind
the laundry and in green bay
the key distinction is the fans also own
the team so they're even more inclined
when push comes to shove between
franchise and player
they're going to side with the franchise
and if player violates his contract and
stays away
player becomes the one with whom they're
the most upset which makes them less
inclined to be upset
with mark murphy or brian gudekunst on
top of that
they get to find out what jordan love
has the expectations plummet
for 2020 and after the year
the packers not having to worry about
rogers playing for another team
and maybe winning a super bowl and
making them look stupid
for moving him to another team or
setting the stage for him to want out by
drafting jordan love
you don't have to worry about that this
year you trade him after the season
and i still think that the packers get
more trading rogers
after 2021 than they would get trading
him now because you're gonna have more
teams who have gone through a full
season
who have decided this quarterback that
we believed in we no longer believe in
let's get in the running for aaron
rodgers there will be more teams at the
table
if they decide right now to trade him
it's the broncos and who
who maybe the raiders maybe
and i think from the raiders perspective
they'd have to consider it because
we don't want him to go to the broncos
so i
i i think that the best way for rogers
to get out
may be to show up this is where i was
heading with all that
i think that even though the packers
have shown no inclination to trade aaron
rodgers
i think if he shows up and
murphy and gouda kunst and the board of
directors and the executive committee
all realized
this is going to be a very awkward and
stressful season
everyone is just coming off of what was
a very awkward and stressful 2020
because of the pandemic because think
about it even though they got all the
games in
i was talking to somebody about this
yesterday there was a constant sense
of holding your breath while waiting for
the bottom to fall out of the season
every week when's it going to happen
when's it going to happen who's going to
be the team that can't play a game when
are they going to have to cancel games
where are they going to play the games
they canceled when are they going to
play the games they canceled what
happens if they don't play all the games
are they going to determine playoff
spots based on win percentage remember
that was a
big topic last year i don't think the
packers want another year
where they're worried about something
every week and this year
instead of worrying about the pandemic
they're worrying about what aaron
rodgers is going to say or do
that will will cause a mini brush fire
that they need to worry about we know
he's got a propensity to make passive
aggressive comments and we know that
he goes as i know we've seen it we play
the clip all the time
of him calling me out by name during the
i think it was 2016 or 2017 season when
i was connecting the dots to show that
he was making passive aggressive
comments about then coach mike mccarthy
oh
and he was you could see the devil on
one shoulder and the angel on the other
coaxing him the devil was coaxing him to
call me out
the angel said don't give that guy the
benefit don't give him the power
by letting him know that you're reading
what he's writing
and you want people to not waste their
time reading that crap
you know i may put that on my tombstone
i don't know don't waste your time
reading this crap
but i don't think the packers want a
full season
of needing an interpreter to figure out
what it is that aaron rodgers was saying
in his post-game press conference or in
his midweek press conference mandatory
press availabilities that he has so to
finally land this plane
so that you're not wasting your time
listening to this crap
i think if he shows up there's a chance
the packers decide to trade him there's
a chance that they give the broncos a
call
there's a chance that come week one
it'll be jordan love versus either
jameis winston or taysom hill
and aaron rodgers will be starting for
the denver broncos
there's a chance that happens if he
shows up
so aaron to get out
you may have to get in you may have to
show
up because i think when you show up
and maybe hey look maybe this is super
genius
evil genius aaron rodgers realizing
how to manipulate the situation he's
created enough chaos
in the off-season to make mark murphy
not want him there so easiest solution
he doesn't show up
great he shows up oh boy
now we got to deal with him all year
let's just go ahead and trade him
and be done with it now that leads to
one more topic that i want to get to i
was on wqam in miami this morning with
zach krantz joe rose who's been hosted
that show for years and i've been on
that show every friday morning
for years uh joe was off zach and i were
talking about
the rogers situation and he raised the
question of
how many teams would rogers make
into super bowl contenders immediately
if the trade happened right now
regardless of who they currently have
and
obviously there are a lot of teams that
already are super bowl contenders
without aaron rodgers or yes they're
they're already
like the bills yeah the bills are a
super bowl contender with josh allen
if for some reason the bills would
decide to trade for aaron rodgers which
they would never do because they have
josh allen they're still a super bowl
contender
so what i've done is i've gone through
team by team
and i'm curious about
the teams that currently aren't in my
mind based upon their
their present quarterback situation true
super bowl contenders
does rogers make them into contenders
yes or no
now before i get to that here are the
teams that i think are contenders
with or without aaron rodgers super bowl
contenders
with or without rogers on the team
the bills the patriots and yes i believe
the patriots are super bowl contenders
given the upgrades they've made this off
season and the presence
of bill belichick as the head coach
the steelers the browns the ravens the
titans the colts
the chiefs and the chargers in the afc
those are the teams that i think are
super bowl contenders
with or without aaron rodgers in the nfc
the cowboys
and even though i think washington is
going to win the division i think if it
works for the cowboys they're more
likely to be a super bowl contender if
that makes any
sense so i'm going to say the cowboys
the only super bowl contender out of the
nfc east for now even though i think
washington wins the division
the buccaneers the saints the rams
the seahawks and the 49ers those are all
the teams that are super bowl contenders
if for some reason they would decide hey
let's go ahead and get aaron rodgers and
the packers will trade him now here are
the teams
that become contenders for the super
bowl
who i currently think aren't you put in
aaron rodgers and they're contenders
the dolphins become super bowl
contenders they currently aren't
the raiders become super bowl contenders
in my mind they currently aren't the
broncos
become super bowl contenders in my mind
they currently aren't washington
becomes a super bowl contender in my
mind even though i think they're going
to win the division i don't think
they're going to have enough
to punch through to the super bowl the
vikings become super bowl contenders in
my mind
they currently aren't the bears they're
not going to do it
but they would become super bowl
contenders in my mind they currently
aren't
and then the others i've added the
panthers
and the cardinals i don't think either
team is a super bowl contender
right now i think they would be with
aaron rodgers the teams i struggled with
were the falcons and
the giants i put them on the nose side
and these are the teams that i think
aaron rodgers wouldn't make them into
super bowl contenders jets bengals
texans jaguars giants eagles lions
falcons
but the two on which i was the closest
are the giants
and the falcons and it's no coincidence
that they're nfc teams because
the afc is so damn top heavy i don't
care who the quarterback
is of the jets this year they're not a
super bowl contender they're not
ready yet from a personnel standpoint
the bengals have a long way to go to be
super bowl contenders the texans have
the worst roster in the nfl right now
and the jaguars have a long way to go as
well not that the jaguars
would want aaron rodgers if the
opportunity arose or the bengals for
that matter or the jets for that matter
again
there aren't many teams that would want
him right now
i think the broncos are the clear leader
right now
the raiders as i said could get into it
and the other side of it too and i'm
glad i thought of this
rogers has to want to go to the team
that would trade for him
and some of you will say in response to
that but he doesn't have a no trade
clause
well for a starting quarterback
a no trade clause is meaningless
because think about this if you're the
general manager of a team
and you are trading for a quarterback
a guy that you want to come in and set
the tone for the organization
show up stay late hold teammates
accountable
check every box and then some be the
face of the team at least from the
locker room standpoint if you don't want
to be there
do you really want him i think a key
ingredient
to making it work especially at this
stage of the year
is to have full buy-in from the
quarterback so hey the dolphins become
super bowl contenders with aaron rodgers
but if aaron rodgers doesn't want to
live and play in miami this year
if he doesn't want to be on the dolphins
this year you're not going to make that
trade
because he don't want to be there he may
not show up remember when richard
seymour was traded from the patriots to
the raiders and it took a few days for
him to recognize
oh god i've been traded from one of the
best teams in the nfl to one of the
worst at the time the raiders were one
of the worst
it took them a while to realize i've
just better go now it's easier to do
that
with a non-quarterback a quarterback can
say fine i'll show up
but don't expect me to do all the stuff
that a quarterback
who's all in would do and i think it's
one of the reasons why the bears didn't
go after carson wentz remember they were
linked to carson wentz
wence didn't want to go there wentz
doesn't have no trade clause doesn't
matter
if wence doesn't want to be in chicago
the bears aren't going to waste their
time
trading for him so that's the other
thing to keep in mind if he gets traded
this year
i think it's the broncos maybe the
raiders after
this year there will be more teams at
the table the question is which
teams would aaron rodgers be willing
to play for the problem is i mean think
about it
the west coast teams that's where he
wants to go well the rams have matthew
stafford and they gave up a lot to get
him
they're not going to give up on him
after one year the 49ers who the hell
knows what they're going to do
because they wanted aaron rodgers and
they're so desperate to atone for their
failure
to draft patrick mahomes and their
failure to take tom brady
up on his interest in the team that
maybe they would do something crazy
like throw everyone overboard and go get
aaron rodgers trey lance for aaron
rodgers straight up
maybe that would happen who knows the
raiders and the broncos i think would
still be the two teams to watch
next year but maybe the possibility of
having more teams at the table
could leverage one of those teams to
give up more and of course from roger's
perspective he doesn't want
the team he's going to to give up too
much
because he's got to go play for that
team you don't want the team to be
gutted
you don't want the team's draft picks
for the next several years to all be
gone
as part of the transaction that brought
you there so
uh interesting dynamics to say the least
and we'll find out in a couple of weeks
whether he
shows up but the bottom line is i think
if he shows up
that gives him a better chance to get
out this year
instead of next year couple of questions
ted thunderman
if the vikings decide calamond is the
guy next offseason which teams would be
on the list to trade for kirk cousins
or will it need to be another brock
osweiler type of a trade to unload the
contract next year
kirk cousins makes 35 million fully
guaranteed
i don't know that they'd have to do a
brock osweiler deal to get rid of him
i think what the vikings are likely to
do because i think they're going to make
the playoffs this year
so i don't think the vikings are going
to flip
from cousins to mond in the 2022 off
season
i think what happens is come
2022 if they think monde is ready
and if they think monde is the guy
cousins goes on
short leash and if the team struggles
like it did
in 2020 they were not good
at the start of the year to say the
least if they struggle
then that's when mon gets his chance and
kirk cousins at that point becomes the
highest paid backup quarterback in
league history i think that's how it
plays out i think they have the cap
space
in order they understand they got to
take their medicine on the cousins deal
they have monde on a third-round rookie
contract so they can get away with that
you look at the full dollars allocated
to the quarterback position is it fair
that monde isn't getting
very many in relation to cousins no but
from the vikings perspective
we have cousins we have monde for two
years
it's cousins this year without question
next year i think going into the year
will be cousins without question
and then if questions arise they'll flip
them on and then it makes it easier
when the season ends for the vikings to
let cousins walk away which is i think
what will happen ultimately i
i'm convinced it's cousin's team barring
injury wire to wire this year
and i'm convinced after next year
cousins will be gone
very important question from paul zulak
who's the best character on seinfeld not
including the four main characters all
signs point
to david putty i'm a big david putty fan
but
look i don't know if it's the
sentimentality because jerry stiller
passed
not that long ago the months and the
weeks and the years are starting to blur
together
but but i love frank costanza
francostanza makes me laugh like no one
else on that show and frank costanza i
think stole
every single scene that he was in that's
what makes him in my mind my favorite
beyond
the main four characters tom marshall
otherwise known
as a red zone alk who starts more games
this year desean watson or jameis
winston that's a great question and of
course anytime anyone says that's a
great question that just means
i'm buying time because i don't know
what the answer to the question should
be
i'll say hmm
see we don't know enough right now to
know what's up with deshaun watson
will he settle the cases before camp
with each passing
day hour minute it becomes less likely
but it can happen at any time
if he doesn't settle before camp will
they put him on paid leave
the nfl as i've said time and again owes
it to watson the texans and any
interested teams to let everyone know
where he stands
before training camp begins
all that said
i'm going to go with winston but you
could flip a coin on it
we don't know enough yet to know for
sure based on what we know now
my hunch is we're going to see more
starts from winston than watson
but that could change really by the end
of the day
if this weekend's friday afternoon
bad news dump includes the news that the
watson cases have settled
valleyman 12 what would constitute a
successful season for the new york jets
why winning the super bowl of course
right isn't that how every team defines
success no
no that's how every team says it defines
success
so the fans believe that the team is
trying to get to the top of the same
mountain that the fans
want want want fans want conjugation
error fans want the team too i
i think that 500
well you know what you can't be 500
anymore eight eight and one eight eight
and one
or better would be a successful season
for the new york jets
and it would lay the foundation if they
would get to eight eight and one or
better this year
that would lay the foundation for them
to become contenders as soon as next
year
let's see what else we have
at jewish writer not a question but you
said with respect to kyle shanahan maybe
there is a strategy there that i am not
capable of grasping
it's called strategic transparency
players scouts others in the
organization and fans respect
kyle's honesty it also helps steer
reporters towards the stories rather
than making
up some tabloid negativity it actually
has been very
successful for him i don't buy it i
don't buy it don't buy it
i don't buy it because
i look at the greatest coach of all time
in any sport bill belichick he doesn't
say crap
if if there was value to strategic
transparency
bill belichick would be engaged in it
i think the most recent thing that
happened
sean mcveigh invites kyle shanahan to
appear on sean mcvay's podcast kyle
shanahan
knows that if he says no he comes off
as chicken like marty mcfly
timely reference he doesn't want to be
called a chicken
he doesn't want to be perceived as a
chicken come on kyle we're just going to
talk football come on
what are you afraid of we're just going
to talk we're just going to talk
so kyle basically allows himself to be
shamed into doing it because he doesn't
want to look like he's afraid of having
a conversation
on the record with his top rival
and clearly sean mcvay is his top rival
they play each other twice a year
mcveigh's got the team right now that
would be regarded as the best on paper
in the nfc west
and then kyle starts talking and kyle
says things
and i think once kyle gets to talking he
can't keep himself
from saying things so
you know let me let me let me give you
the best example
now i'm not this way anymore but there
was a time that
if i had one of those big ass bags of m
ms the peanut ones you know like the
the big giant one pound bag
if that thing was in my house
i could not resist eating all
of the peanut m m's in one sitting now
if it wasn't there i'm not thinking
about peanut m
ms i'm not going to go to the store and
buy a giant bag of peanut m
ms i can walk right by that aisle
at the grocery store and i love going to
the grocery store i can walk right by it
and not
buy the big ass yellow bag of peanut m
ms but if that thing's in my house
it's not surviving and i don't know i
just kind of came up with that because i
think it explains
how kyle needs to protect himself from
himself for me
it meant not letting the big ass bag of
peanut m
m's into the house for kyle i think it
means
not putting himself in situations where
he is going
to say stuff that does not help him
it does not help him to talk about how
he wanted matthew stafford it does not
help him
to talk about these issues openly
because at the end of the day as i said
yesterday the perception that's been
created
the 49ers wanted any quarterback they
could find they wanted to throw a rock
and get a quarterback who would be
better than jimmy garoppolo at the end
of the day they gave up three first
round picks and a third round pick
to draft a rookie who is stuck behind
jimmy garoppolo on the depth chart
barring whatever happens at training
camp makes me think
because i i've i don't want to waver
from my position
from the moment they traded up i said
well see you later jimmy
goodbye jimmy it's been nice hope you
find your paradise
i i still think that they're gonna
hope that some other quarterback gets
injured
and not jimmy g because then they'd
still own 25 million
and they can trade him and if they get
to that
last week of the preseason you know
there's not going to be a fourth
preseason game this year there's a bye
week they have time to shape the rosters
that's when they go to jimmy g and they
say hey bro
we can't pay you 25 million trade lance
is ready to go you want to stay
you got to take 15 million pay cut
and you you're probably gonna be on the
bench
we'll keep you but you're not making 25
million and then or
maybe they just cut them maybe they
don't even give them the chance to take
less
maybe they say we're all in with trade
lands because look if we can't trust you
to stay healthy as the backup
how can we trust this day or this is the
starter how can we trust you to stay
healthy is the backup
so all this talk
from shanahan and all these admissions
that they wanted matthew stafford sam
darnold
aaron rodgers mac jones trey lance
it makes it even more confusing that
they would be ready to go into the 2021
season with jimmy garoppolo
as the starter because if he does stay
healthy all year like he did two years
ago i mean it's not like he's gerald
ford
tripping down the steps of the airplane
every time he gets off of it
2019 he went wire to wire 2018 he didn't
2020 he didn't 2021 maybe he goes wire
to wire
maybe you get back to the super bowl
maybe he misses a throw with the game on
the line
but we went to the super bowl we're
gonna dump the guy that took us to the
super bowl
i just look i
i i still think the 49ers have been
freaked out by the fact that they were
caught looking on patrick mahomes and
they swung and missed on tom brady
i i believe that uh
i i i just i don't see the benefit
and to the extent that there is
strategic transparency going on i don't
think it's a good plan
because it's created the impression that
the 49ers
who are led by a coach that i think
could become the next bill belichick and
i still believe that
he he just needs to put a sock in it and
that runs counter to every instinct that
i have
when it comes to operating
a media outlet that is premised on
people talking and i'm frustrated by the
fact that bill belichick won't talk
because there are things you can say
that don't hurt you strategically
i just i think that if if shanahan wants
to be bill belichick
he needs a good consigliary he needs
somebody who can whisper in his ear kyle
stop it
just stop it just don't do it don't do
it
when you think about doing it do the
opposite all right that's it for now
um next week tbd
i'm not going to commit i'm not going to
commit
because i'm going to take the equipment
i'm going to take the big laptop with
the microphone and
i'm not gonna lug the light that i use
when i when i do these down in the
basement
but uh i'm gonna i'm gonna be ready at
our undisclosed location
somewhere in the eastern portion of the
united states to do some videos
we'll just we'll see we'll see you know
how it is you say it now
but you feel very differently once you
get there and i've been there and i've
done that i'm gonna feel very
differently
once it's beach life so maybe by monday
uh i won't have any desire to do it but
but we'll see i'll keep you posted
and we've got plenty of videos from this
week plenty of great stuff that the guys
from brother from another got out at
tahoe for the american century
championship so you'll see plenty of
videos you can catch up on that
either way we'll be back soon and either
way the one thing i do
when we are on vacation i will
constantly be
writing content whether or not you want
to waste your time reading
that crap is up to you but it will be
there for you all week long
next week every single day of every week
of every month of every year at pft
thanks for some of your time
be safe enjoy your weekend and we'll see
you again real soon
you